je déclare ouverte la 38e et dernière
cérémonie libre des césar et à dieu
qu'est-ce qui va payer toit s'est amené
dans un mois je suis pas prêt de faire
l'amour tout le temps comme ça faut que
je bosse
ici nous arrive lambert la vie continue
il est temps que il est temps que céline
sorte de mon corps a cédé à céline
battant c'est le césar du meilleur
espoir féminin ainsi qu'une paire de
chaussures en argent magique de céline
dion sont attribués
quelle taille la paire de chaussures 44
filles est la mienne à izia higelin
bonsoir j'ai fait du 41 ça va être un
peu juste mais merci infiniment
je suis extrêmement ému extrêmement
touchée je vous remercie à l'académie
d'avoir voté pour moi et c'est trop bien
merci
voilà la musique toujours et maintenant
le cinéma j'espère aussi beaucoup
voyager aller danser seul dans un coin
de nos moeurs
non mais c'est vrai par exemple l'année
dernière meilleure actrice vous souvenez
qui étaient nommés n'ont par contre vous
souvenir très bien qu'il a eue
bérénice bejo pardon bérénice béjo non
c'est moi qui l'ait
non c'est bérénice bejo dans dix
artistes mais non c'est dujardin dans
the artist
et le césar de la meilleure actrice est
attribué à bérénice bejo dans dix
artistes
voilà c'est moi en vous étiez à deux
doigts de me faire douter
bon alors
yes kevin yes it's now she comes from
roumania
and she goes by them trouve nous oui je
translates to find her
je suis énormément touchée d'être
accueilli de cette façon dans la famille
française sais pas quoi dire
d'abord il faut que je remercie jacques
jacques audiard qui qui m'a emmené dans
cette histoire d'amour tellement
puissante inoubliable j'espère qu'il y
en aura d'autres
avec lui j'ai connu trois génies dans ma
vie jacques en est un le scénario c'est
la colonne vertébrale d'un film et la
moelle épinière que sont les que les
actes et les acteurs qui les acteurs qui
en fait qui sent la moelle épinière que
sans la colonne vertébrale sept mois
c'est la moelle épinière que sont les
acteurs ne trouvera il ne trouvera ne
saurait pas où ce coût se situe où se
situer le squelette
le squelette total d'un squelette global
le squelette d'un film qui en fait le
rallye
le réalisateur qui est le losc le
squelette de ce film ne bénéficierait
pas de cette moelle épinière et il ne
pourrait pas marcher alors
comme c'est pas facile on fait d'ouvrir
les enveloppes parce que par cas leur
parpaing je peux pas ouvert voilà donc
je vais m'en charger il ya des lignes
délicat et le césar de la meilleure
actrice dans un second rôle est attribué
à valérie benguigui dans le présent vous
pourrez faire un peu de pub du
bodybuilding je n'ai pas d'humour devait
pas du monde on n'a pas respecté les
lignes pardon chez je suis premier degré
excusez moi mais j'ai trop ému pour ra
pour comprendre les plans je crois j'ai
l'impression que j'ai juste une
dimension là c'était vraiment l'année
des surprises et voilà et je voudrais
aussi je pense à mes enfants mais aussi
ce we président je office césar est un
drame on en est aux enfants on en est
aux enfants président ouais je suis fier
de vous et et surtout je voudrais dédier
ce césar à mon amoureux depuis 26 ans
eric va plaire voilà c'est pour toi
merci décor un décor je te dis qu tu me
dis qu ils ceux des cobras nounou
hamon
j'ai encore en acadie 12h06 là
dans diverses merci merci beaucoup
bonsoir ghiwane chacun devrait connaître
ça au moins une fois dans sa vie
kind of stuff mais cet honneur clown
fait affirme martin qu'il va droit au
coeur
merci d'accepter pour ça quand je suis
je suis en arrêt vous ne nous avez
offert à ma femme christine ya un mois
une soirée fantastique
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
il ya un système insupportable on veut
le tout savoir c'est vrai c'est vrai
merci merci pour ce que tu as dit
antoine le césar de la meilleure actrice
est attribué à emmanuel riba rabbo
j'ai toujours envie de le cacher quand
je reçois la bonté des prix 2 comment
dire je ne peux pas le concevoir ce
procès guère possible de ne pas le
penser pour avec toute l'équipe du film
ça m'est difficile de d'être tout seul
avec ça cc c'est tellement cher
tellement précieux je regrette
j'aurais beaucoup aimé que jean louis
trintignant soit là que mes filles à la
mena que soit la fin j'ai fait j'ai
travaillé dans ce film avec une une très
grande passion
je dois dire je vous remercie beaucoup
marla nous aider
il est il est plus lourd que moi
le césar du meilleur acteur est attribué
à jean louis trintignant
bonsoir oui donc jean-louis n'a pas pu
venir il est il est au théâtre à
bruxelles ce soir voilà je joue je
voulais moi vous simplement remercier
toute l'équipe de ce film parce que
depuis qu'il a fait ce film sur les sur
les deux vieux qui vont mourir baïla
bien rajeuni les bienheureux donc ça ça
fait du bien je par contre on va essayer
de l'appeler parce que normalement il a
terminé sa représentation et on va
essayer de le joindre va pas répondre
alors il un je regarde la télé a
maintenant pas si si si si je tente en
tente en bas c'est comme si tu avais
beaucoup redoublé mais ça y est tu l'as
eu le césar fait avant mais je suis très
content merci merci beaucoup je remercie
tous tous merci tout s'est bien voté
pour moi ceux qui n'ont pas voté pour
moi parce que je connais les autres
filets qui jouissant vachement bien
bon bah peux vous dire je suis confus je
suis un peu ému
voilà merci beaucoup
il paraît que vous avez pris du retard
je vous donne l'occasion de le rattraper
au moins j'aurai fait un truc important
je vous en remercie votre look et comme
ici le président de cette 38e cérémonie
je vais pas ouvrir cet angle
savard nouveaux élèves en rigole j'en
étais sûr il lui méritant le césar du
meilleur film est attribué à amour
meilleure forme en direct et légaux et
réalisé par michael haneke
ça fait du bien d'être là en tant que
producteur aussi pas seulement comme
porte parole du scénariste et du metteur
en scène mais il me manque toujours géré
préféré qu'il soit à mes côtés que
d'être là tout seul
vous êtes qui moi je dit margaret
margaret dit que parce que tout le monde
ne sait pas que vous êtes le regard est
pas beau tant pis pour eux margaret
menegoz
la productrice j'ai rarement les
producteurs sont dans la lumière
voilà donc ils me connaissent pas ces
normes
c'est normal merci à vous tous et soeurs
un séjour peut-être et comme je dis
toujours gloire au vainqueur
honneur aux vaincus